I hate the Haram police, bro. I'm not
Sneo. Shut the [__] up and get out of my
chat, you [__] ass [__] Like, like,
yo, I I will literally tell you guys to
[__] up. You Haram police [__] are
literally content killers, bro. You guys
are vibe killers. You guys are content
killers. Out of here, man. Go do some D
with somewhere else. Like, I'm not
scared of you, [__] ass [__] Go read
the Quran somewhere else, man. Like,
I'll roast your [__] I do not give a
[__] Get the [__] out my chat, bro. I'm
not scared of you [__] Like, I
don't give a [__] Get the [__] out my
[__] you annoying [__] peasants. You
guys are annoying as [__]
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says.
You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count, brothers and
sisters. And donate towards this
message, inshallah, a new project that's
only $500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1, £10, £100,
£1,000. That's going to be something you
will never regret on your makyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds and your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Asalam alaikum to brothers and sisters
and dear friends. I came across this
video from Myron and you know with him
obviously um in double minds certain
stuff that he says I don't really agree
agree with. There's a lot of stuff he
says I agree as well. But I found this
video a little bit disturbing because I
just want to know like he claims to be a
Muslim but where does his loyalties lie?
Now here's him absolutely going mental
and I don't really blame him but the
foul language is not called for. Okay.
So there's some people commenting and
saying to him that he's a disbeliever.
This is the issue with a lot of Muslims.
Okay, you guys are very very toxic in
the comment section. You're judgmental.
You know, you call people unjustly by
the way. Not just if someone was doing
wrong and you came and said it in a way
like in a specific way. It's fine. You
get it. But you guys are very very
judgmental. You guys pick on everything
and anything. And you are the reason why
so many people run away from Islam. And
it's very bizarre because a lot of
people accuse this of me when subhan all
you man I have never attacked or given
to anybody except they have
transgressed. Okay. Except they are the
ones who are transgressing one way or
another. I'm talking about unjustly
judging people. Yes. Argument say
sisters um wearing a um tight clothing
or whatever it is. Oh, she's probably
like this. She's probably like that. You
can't do that. Do you get it? You cannot
go and pick on somebody just because of
their dressings. But anyways, uh let's
um wash this inshallah and make
judgments. Yeah, he is gripping all the
Christians in the chat. Lol. And you're
not Muslim. Shut shut. See, [__] like
the problem, bro. People like you are
the [__] This is why so many [__]
like, I hate the haram police, bro. I'm
not sne up and get out my chat. You
[__] ass [__] Like, like, yo, I I
will literally tell you guys to [__] up.
You haram police [__] are literally
content killers, bro. You guys are vibe
killers. You guys are content killers.
Out of here, man. Go do some da
somewhere else. Like, I'm not scared of
you, [__] ass [__] Go read a Quran
somewhere else, man. Like, I'll roast
your [__] I do not give a [__] Get
the [__] out my chat, bro. I'm not
scared of you [__] Like I
don't give a [__] Get the [__] out of
my [__] You annoying [__] peasants.
You guys are annoying as [__] You
around police [__] bro. You guys are
the [__] worst. You guys are like
[__] takes. It's like I just want to
smack the [__] out of y'all [__] Man,
you guys are [__] annoying. And
here's the thing. Nobody likes you guys.
You guys realize this. Like the only
people that tolerate your [__] are the
ML [__] You guys send in the M
talking about, "Oh, I'm a bigger devout
follower than you. I'm a bigger devout
follower than you. I'm not doing this
much. I'm doing this much." Oh, well I I
I'm going to have I'm going to get
married tomorrow. Shut the [__] up, man.
Shut the [__] up. You guys are Get the
[__] out my chat, man. I don't [__]
like you guys at tell you haram police
are the [__] worst. You guys are
[__] the biggest losers, the biggest
hypocrites. You [__] are whacking off
the porn every [__] day talking about
Muslim. Get the [__] out of here you
[__] ass [__] By day you read fat.
By night you [__] whacking off
fapping all over the place. Get the [__]
out of here. Okay so obviously as you
can see there was a little beep going
etc. I understand his frustration but
his thing of oh you read the Quran at
day and do this do two wrongs will make
it right. Everyone's a sinner. Everyone
has their shortfalls etc. The point uh
is not that the point is that you know
um which I understand which is a lot of
people coming out there and making
judgments like to call him a non-Muslim.
Again there is question marks on him.
Yes. But we can give Nia in a specific
way. Now I want to go to some other
videos where he says some stuff which
I'm find quite worrying and concerning
in so let's go to the first one. Here is
this.
>> Look man, I've been in different
circles. I talk to people from different
places. I tell you guys all the time
when people talk [__] about blacks I
tell you what people say about blacks
minded back. With Muslims we got to have
a real discussion here. People get
really annoyed when you try to shove
your way of life and your religion down
their throat. Nobody gives a that you
pray five times a day. Nobody cares that
you're religious. Nobody cares that you
cover yourself up. Nobody cares about
none of that [__] Where people start to
get annoyed is when you try to put your
way of life out there outwardly. What's
it? I don't know what you mean, my who's
who's shoving the religion of who? Who?
There's no compulsion in Islam. You
claim to be a Muslim. Okay. Knowing our
religion tells us that we have to
enforce our religion other people. So
what are you talking about?
>> Where people have to accept what you do.
This is why so many people have a
negative connotation of Islam cuz you
guys want to come in. You want to shove
it down their throat. You want to force
[__] to do the shahada. You want to
force [__] to pray. Bro, nobody wants
to hear that [__] People want to be
able to practice their religion without
you judging them, without you giving
them a headache, without them having to
hear that done. They don't want to hear
it, bro. This ain't your country. Sorry.
Go to a Muslim country if you want that
[__] There's plenty of them. There's
like 50. Okay. So, what's that supposed
to do with being in a country or a
country? I understand your frustration
in the sense where if people are
enforcing their self on you, nobody's
enforcing anything on you. So, what are
you talking about? And you talk about
American record like as if you like
sadly it comes across as if you like
worship like America comes from before
you're you're an American before you're
a Muslim my friend America is not going
to save you on day judgment my when you
are in front of God Almighty not America
none of this stuff is going to matter
okay so this nationalist idea and it
just comes across you're just trying to
appease to these people okay so to me I
found that very bizarre and odd uh you
seem very very triggered when it comes
to Islam I don't know why I don't know
if it's you have a guilty conscience or
it's like you're not as practicing
whatever it You know, cuz sometimes like
in your debates and stuff that you have
with all these other women, etc. that
you're sitting with, which is not
permissible. I was I understand you say,
"Oh, I'm not practicing." But yeah, so
you're there, you like to know your
facts, you know, you like to put them on
the spot. You like to make them feel
guilty, which okay, if they're guilty,
that's charged. But it seems like you
have this maybe issue where because you
know you're guilty because you know
you're not practicing. When people call
you out, you don't like it. But you do
this to other women. You do it to other
women by not by calling them out
rightly. So, uh, not taking them to
account, etc. I don't believe I agree
the theme and those are half naked girls
and all that kind of stuff. You talk
about sleeping around with girls. That's
haram. Please like with all due respect
I don't give if you're practicing not
practicing. If you're a Muslim you can't
go and say steepers go commit zu what
are you talking about you know. So if
you can call them out and keep them in
check etc whatever it is and speak facts
to them. If someone I don't I'm not
asking anyone to come and do it rudely
or be judgmental etc. But if people are
coming saying to you hold on a second my
we need to call you out here etc. Why
you why are you bugging up? Why you
bugging? you do do it to other people,
you know, don't serve a dish that you
cannot eat yourself, you know. So, we
have to call you and say, "Hold on a
second. Muslim practicing or no, you say
you're a Muslim and there are certain
things." So, what's this thing about
America? Go back to your country. You've
done this before many times. I don't
understand. I hope you guys enjoyed the
video, guys. But before that, please
download the Salah Pro app. Brothers and
sisters, we are a charity. All of our
services on the app is for free. Free
Kiblinder. No ads. Free Salah reminders.
Encourages to pray. Tells you salah
times. You can book a salah instructor,
a Quran instructor. You can order a
guided prayer map for absolutely free if
you want to learn how to pray salah.
Videos on how to pray salah. Salah hubs
and many many more broken sisters. We
are not an app that shares your
information with third parties. All of
our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah and enjoy
guys. Let's go back to the video. Here's
a red pill for you guys that you guys
really got to understand. Okay? And
Muslims are going to get mad at me for a
second, but I'm going to say it anyway.
I'm going to say it anyway. Does not
teach you to critically think. I'm
sorry. Okay? They teach you the Quran.
You're supposed to memorize suras. It's
a very let's memorize approach. Okay,
rehearse, memorize, have the Quran
memorized, etc. Cool. Whatever. Right?
It doesn't really push you to critically
think. Okay? It's a very structured
religion. This is the way it is. It's
very rigid. You're going to learn this
surah. You're going to learn this surah.
You're going to learn how to pray, do
the woo in this way, etc. It's very
systemic and it's created that way so
people know how to follow. It's a very
good guideline for life, right? It is.
But the problem is that these guys don't
get it. Like, yo, I understand that
Islam has this way of doing things. I'm
Muslim myself. I get it. But guess what?
This isn't Saudi Arabia. This isn't
Sudan. This isn't Egypt. This isn't
Lebanon. This isn't Syria. This isn't
Iran. This isn't like, I'm sorry, bro.
Like, this is not a Muslim country.
>> One second. Firstly, um, like you said
there, Islam doesn't ask you to have
critical thinking. Of course, it does.
It's the only religion that tells you to
have critical thinking. Allah tells you
in the Quran um indeed in the creation
of the heavens and the earth and in the
alternation of the night and day there
are signs for those who have intellect
the ones who critically think. Yes. So
this notion like I don't know what
you've been taught but you're making it
seem as if like we are like um cavemen.
Yeah. Whoever like sorry Allah tells us
to use your use your logic look around
ponder and if you do you would realize
that God might exist. So I don't
understand what you mean by who which
who says that we're coming here to shove
our religion that other people from? No,
we propagate Islam and if majority of
the country come to Islam, it will be an
Islamic country. As simple as that.
We're just saying give us the freedom of
speech to carry on spreading Islam and
if people choose Islam, you can't stop
it. And that's the issue because the
same the time of the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him, he propagated Islam,
people came to Islam, they did not like
it. And it's the same with these people
who have this world. Oh, we're about
freedom of speech. No, you're not.
Because the moment if Americans realize
Islam is the truth, what will happen? A
civil war will happen because they don't
want Islam. So this bull crap of freedom
of speech is nonsense. Anyways guys look
in a nutshell all I want to say to my is
listen brother okay you are a brother in
Islam you saying you're a Muslim
alhamdulillah but you know sometimes
your loyalty seem like there somewhere
else now I understand you might not be
around people that are practicing
religious and we can have that
conversation you get what I'm trying to
say and you don't need to have it with
me you can't with anyone else Muhammad
etc you invite people to your podcast
like Tommy Robinson who's somebody that
insults your messenger Imagine I have
someone in my podcast who insults your
mom would you like that you would not
like that so establish your loyalties
bro your loyalties should be you can't
have one or the other. Like IBM said,
you can't have music and Quran in the
same heart. So, brother, all we're
saying to you is, you know, just a
gentle reminder cuz I don't want to come
across like this haram police. I'm
judging you, etc. I know you're going to
be watching this video. You're a brother
in Islam. We have nothing but love for
you. Me saying this and doing this video
is is genuine love, bro. I don't have
any. You might think, "Oh, it's do for
the clicks and the views. What money,
man? What money? What money do you think
I make with what do you think I make?£50
from this video? 20? What What What kind
of like I'm trying to say?" Genuinely,
we're saying this because at the end of
the day, life is short. Your priority is
in the wrong place. Bro, imagine if you
die today, bro. If you die today, every
single people around you are going to
forget you, bro. They don't care.
They're all materialist. They're about
the world. They don't care. Have people
around you that's going to care about
you, that's going to benefit you in the
hereafter. So, I'm saying to you,
brother, please put your loyalty to
Islam first. Nobody's shoving their
religion down anyone's throat. Nobody's
saying this has to be Sharia country,
this that. Nobody's doing that. So,
where are you getting these false
perceived notions from? I don't know.
So, again, we ask Allah subhana wa tala
to guide you and guide myself.
Inshallah, we're both sinners in
different ways and haram. police. Like I
said before, guys, you guys have become
very, very toxic. Okay, you're attacking
everybody, judging everybody. Take it
easy. There's a way and method to do it.
Yes, sometimes you have to be harsh. I
do that. Sometimes when you need to be
harsh, you need to be harsh. But if
you're continuously doing that to
everybody, it's a no-go. That's what I
want to say, bro. Inshallah, may Allah
guide our brother Myron close to Islam
and myself inshallaham.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced. The moment you die, that's
what Allah says.
You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count, brothers and
sisters, and donate towards this
message, inshallah, a new project that's
only $500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1, £10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makyama. And
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds on your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.